et le bal costumé des monstres ma
famille va adorer
je vous ordonne d'envoûter cette femme
et de la transformer en vampire
pourquoi on est les seules personnes à
porter des déguisements
vous
transformez août ce soit génial en plus
maintenant il va se mettre dedans
je suis une horrible sorcière j'ai des
toiles sur tout le corps pourquoi ces
bandages sont collés papa
c'est bien
je suis le parrain immobilisait denis
des jumeaux
mais noah gel maintenant c'est à moi de
prendre le relais les créatures à quatre
pattes doivent être tenus en laisse à
quatre pattes vous dit
je suis la ps2
[Musique]
on va retrouver la sorcière et elle va
nous rendre notre appartement qu en
famille
bonne
famille l'autre